uh okay I have a clerk great
okay
we will open up the public hearing on
House Bill 210 relative to fire
insurance contracts in here from the
prime sponsor representative good
afternoon representative good afternoon
Mr chairman
I am very pleased to be here because
everyone who tried to mess up my
schedule today did a really good job of
it and I got here like two minutes ago
so so this was perfect yes we did mess
up your schedule so I know you all had a
nice lunch so I am going to bore you to
tears with some ridiculously in the
weeds insurance
my name is representative will infantine
I represent Hillsborough 16.
um I'm here to introduce house bill 210.
I am an insurance agent by trade I sit
in the board of directors of the uh
National Insurance agent Association and
I've submitted this on the request of
the insurance department
the bill clarifies
the items in the law that regulate fire
insurance now in the old days I'm
talking about the 60s because this is
what we're trying to do we're trying to
replace something that is in the law
that was written in the 60s and
something that's also written in the 80s
that have a little bit of
redundancy in them and in the 60s
insurance policies were very basic you
had a fire policy and you had a
liability policy and there were other
different little things that were were
all separate little policies today
you've all heard of the expression of
package policy everyone's talking on TV
about a bundle all right you put all
this stuff together a Bop business
owner's policy they put all this stuff
together and it has fire Insurance
liability insurance cyber liability
sewer and water backup all kinds of cool
little things in there that insurance
companies have learned over the last 30
or 40 Years of what really happens in
life and how to make a policy that's
kind of address those things
so the department recently removed older
statutory language
that is covered by more recent statues
and a much more clear language RSA 4072
a and 407 7 are effectively redundant
statutory sections within the same scope
of what a fire insurance policy is
as I said earlier one's newer ones in
the 60s back when I was born
one was more is in the 80s
both statues in this case provide that
fire Peril portions of any property
but other perils cover on the policy may
vary those are things I just talked to
you about other than just the fire
policy if there's something about wind
and there's something about hail and
there's something about all these
different things that the last time many
of you ever read all your insurance
policies and they're all in there I'm
sure it's a it's a great read for a
Saturday night really after you're done
reading the the state of New Hampshire
budget you can read an insurance policy
so that really that's all it does is
take two parts of the of current law
gets rid of one keeps the one that's uh
the newer version in uh 1980s version
all about that very simple peril term we
use Insurance business for a fire
so um
I'll answer a few questions if you'd
like but I'd rather have James Fox from
the Department
um
who really enjoys reading this stuff on
a Saturday night come and talk to you
fair enough thank you very much for your
testimony
so the chair will call on
James Fox in the insurance department
and in particular
uh good afternoon my name is James Fox
from the New Hampshire insurance
department I'm the PNC director with me
as Emily Doherty she's a PNC attorney
you usually have stuff to add but a
representative pretty much covered the
waterfront on this one it is just a
modernization
um
issue that that we had two sections that
had the substantive parts were redundant
and it just goes back to the issue of
the fire policy is the fire policy going
all the way back to when it was mono
lines
and those of you don't know the um fire
policy is actually written into our
statutory scheme 40722
um and it goes back probably that
standard file policy goes back to the
1800s so all of the standards that
circular around that all the 407
standards are designed for fire and this
just says this is for fire not for other
perils so I'm not changing the law we're
just having one standard that's in
essence like once one set of language
really as opposed to two and causing
okay uh any questions from community
members
see none
thank you uh is anybody else would like
to speak on House Bill 210
uh see nobody I will close the public
hearing
Mr chairman may I please hand out an
amendment to the next bill for the
foreign
Churchill
okay
foreign
and
then
was a um they had him on a list and then
I got so excited about putting it into
this date I didn't look at it and say oh
my God I had too much time allocated uh
but we're doing good in terms of getting
bills scheduled
um so hopefully next week we'll have
everything have done in terms of
scheduling and then we will um I might
try for another exact session again next
week in terms of you know subcommittee
in the morning an exec session in the
afternoon
um
the other thing I would tell you I want
everybody to know that in terms of
Tomorrow the subcommittee work you can
see that they were originally laid out
by the two different uh committees but
it looks like one liquor one got kind of
moved up or there was something little
and then we also have in terms of the
hearings
um at the end there was a bill that just
got vacated to this committee which is
that pharmaceutical board that we had
the issue that there was another bill
which is to get rid of it all together
okay so a we so we have these two bills
we have one is that that how do we
improve upon it I guess and the other
one is just to throw the towel in on it
so
um I I schedule that right away so at
least we had that available to us so we
can we know you know we have those tools
I'm not sure either one of them is due
out early
um because I'm trying to push the early
bills uh and in terms of exact session
so in terms of what happens uh tomorrow
and then the exact session my attitude
is that uh we're gonna meet with these
talk about these bills get a feeling for
where everybody is on a bill
um if it becomes clear to me that a bill
is going to be right down the party line
and it's not going to vary then
obviously my attitude is we should just
retain it we don't and why why get us
into an awkward situation on the House
for
um and uh and and and therefore
hopefully
over the over the summer and come next
September when we take up retained bills
we can get some of those issues resolved
and so that we could have something that
we all can agree on which is better than
sending something to the floor where
it's just a partisan battle and then
it's everybody all worried about who's
like maybe maybe I don't know right so
her point was saying that she felt like
last year we didn't spend enough time on
retained bills
um you know and we could have spent more
but I I actually what cramped us last
year was certain members
were on vacation in Europe
not you guys you're the ones who are
here you're the ones running for
reelection it was the ones who weren't
running for re-election that were on
right
okay well we can certainly spend more
it was the you covered leftovers right
so but
anyway
um
all right we're close enough uh we'll
open up the hearing on uh House Bill 479
in here from the prime sponsor
representative infantine good afternoon
good afternoon Mr chairman
for the record I am representative will
infantine from Manchester Hillsboro 16.
I'm here to introduce House Bill 479
um I am as I said earlier I am in in the
insurance industry and have been for 30
or 34 years and I sit in the national
board of directors of our association
I am here at the request of the
insurance department
to place an Omnibus type Bill making
several changes uh I'll I'll be at minor
to three different parts of the
insurance law
and I'm happy to go through as I talk
each line as we go down here on page one
basically the first page lines one
through 25
and all the way to the bottom of the
page and the beginning part the first
five first ten lines of page two have to
do with when an insurance company
comes in front of the insurance
department for any kind of
administrative hearing
situation where they're at fault for
doing something they're not doing
something the insurance department likes
or they want to have a conversation
about something with the insurance
department
so some of the major changes are are
simply changing the word from he to the
commissioner adding an or
um and just some very few small little
changes to what the procedure is going
to be the largest being online is 19
through 25
just gives them a time frame of when
everyone has to respond
when the applicant request May request
additional time so if the commissioner
calls
insurance company in and they say you
want to talk about X Y and Z and the
insurance company has to
go get a whole bunch of information they
can request additional time
so really the first page of this bill
has to do with understanding
if there's an administrative hearing
just redefining what some of the rules
sorry
oh Roman numeral eight
um it says the commissioner shall
provide notice to the insurer by
electronic means specified by the
commissioner the goal here was to update
how we do things you know in the old
days it would say certified mail or or
something and now we're trying to
um
actually bring it up to more modern
times however in reviewing this it was
determined that on line 15 where it says
thus the last two two words on line 15
when either posted on the department's
website
and then the next line the posting on
the department's website were proving to
be not allowable by New Hampshire law
2023-0206h which I handed out
you will note makes those changes
removes
on line 15 and 16 when either post on
the department's website and in line 17
posting on the department's website
those have been removed
and that's the only difference in the
amendment
the third part of this bill clarifies
dishonest acts by Insurance Producers
activities that could negatively affect
the producer's license even those
activities are not insurance
business activities
the commissioner wants
something in the law that he has the
ability to take someone like my
insurance license away if I do something
wrong
if I take the if I steal the money out
of the John Hunt and shouldn't have your
cell phone ringing in committee bucket
and I get turned in for stealing that
money the commissioner needs to know
whether or not that is something that
will affect my ability to be an
insurance agent and have that license
and it gives the um
commissioner the ability to make some
changes you will see on page three
it really starts on the last part
um
line 36 a through H these are all kinds
of things that will get you in trouble
with the insurance commissioner if you
have an insurance license we're trying
to amend letter h
and you'll see in bold type
whether directly as an individual or
through activities for an entity in any
conduct of any business activities or
fraud misre representation or conversion
of funds funds misrepresentation or
breach of fiduciary duty involving
we met an insurance agents Association
met with the uh
insurance commissioner about this and
we're a little concerned thought it went
maybe a little too far
um obviously
never know what can happen in the future
don't want someone's license adversely
effective because it's something totally
absent or different from their job as an
insurance agent But realize the
insurance commission needs that ability
if someone does something through
another organization
um he has the ability then to affect the
license of an insurance agent
so those are the three changes
any questions from committee members yes
thank you uh this could be a nitpicky
question but I in in section four you
talk about
exigent circumstances being one of them
being irreparably uh I think it says
irreparably harmed
could you tell me what irreparably
because at the same I'm sorry at the
same time you also say that you have 30
days so I don't know 30 days seems like
you could
be very irreparably harmed I believe I
have an idea of a circumstance where
that would happen
I'm going to let the insurance
department speak but there are any kind
of situation where someone has thousands
of insurance policies out there
and if something is going on where the
insurance department feels that um it
needs to be done immediately and if not
something is not done there will be
irreparable harm down the line that is
my understanding but I'm going to
um politely not surmise
and let the insurance department answer
okay
anybody else representative
oh
Russian Immaculate uh thank you
commissioner so the way I read this you
could do something that's totally out of
the insurance field and yet the and the
insurance department can pull your
license you you rob a convenience store
in Florida they can pull your insurance
license may they may okay
gives them a little more flexibility of
whether or not
um you know because I I brought up a
situation you know uh I'm having uh
drinks with another couple and my wife
at a local establishment and someone
touches my wife inappropriately and I
hit the guy and I get arrested for
something now this is more financial
just talking about this one but you know
there's always going to be a situation
where would that be good enough to take
my insurance license away probably not
if I was involved with a non-profit
organization and I miss appropriated
some funds that could be grounds for the
insurance commissioner to take away my
okay are we all set thank you
and
good afternoon my name is Heather
Silverstein I'm general counsel from the
New Hampshire insurance department
um yes this Omnibus Bill is again oh
I've spoken before about us reviewing
our statutes as we go along in practice
and as we notice that they have issues
we do try to make changes we do try to
come to the legislature and say uh this
is not working exactly as we would have
hoped and we're trying to make it better
and this is another example of that with
regard to the administrative hearings
piece of this and HB 479
we're clarifying the time for
um
asking for a hearing so when a licensee
needs has a hearing they've been
aggrieved by some decision of the
commissioner and they want to go to
administrative hearing uh our RSA 400a17
is the mechanism to do that
um in the past it was a 30-day window we
would have to go to a hearing right away
now I've been a hearing officer before
and to get that hearing within 30 days
for every single request can be
difficult sometimes but that's not the
only reason that we would change this
there's times when we have a license to
say the sky is falling I need a hearing
like next week
and then
the licensee realizes oh dear I'm not
going to be ready for you next week or I
have other matters that are going to tie
into this hearing and then we'll maybe
get a motion that says please continue
this out for 60 days so it's so for us
you know it's very
um difficult to kind of uh reconcile
that so this is to try to
um help the licensee kind of figure out
that timing yes if you need something
within 60 days because
there's going to be harm irreparable
harm and they would have to just file a
motion and then say what that is we have
a license that say I need to work you
know I I can't you know I'm not going to
be able to go forward if this isn't if
this hearing isn't resolved and because
I have licenses and other
States
and those licenses are affected by
Administrative Hearings in our States
because we talk to each other the states
talk to each other as they should so
this part of the statute is really just
to clean that up as far as the timing
goes for the hearings
and for the administrative fund piece
that's making changes to RSA 400a 39.
this is bringing us up to speed so that
we can just provide notices as to when
these their fee that's due from our
licensees and to to just provide that
electronic knows is fine they can
receive an email and that's sufficient
instead of actual U.S mail and again the
amendment is to the posting on the
website we where we're drawing that
we're not going to consider that to be
proper notice just the email notice and
then the last piece of this is whether
the insurance producer regulation under
RSA 402j and this is
expanding a bit more on the RSA 402 j12h
with regard to dishonest business
practices and just to clarify it's not
just Insurance business practices uh
let's say a trustee misappropriates
money of a trust that's problematic you
wouldn't want that person
handling uh money up in shorts you know
to be a producer so it gives the
commissioner more leeway to
um
suspend or take a license if that's
necessary and if that's proven at a
hearing so
if you have any questions I'd be happy
to take them
thank you I'm asking the same question I
I this is kind of new for me so I'm
trying to understand what is irreparable
harm irreparable harm is similar to the
idea that I was talking about like
someone's livelihood like I need this
hearing right away because this is
affecting my livelihood that's a very
good example and that is actually pretty
commonly argued to us like this notice
of this hearing
administrative hearing the way the laws
work with producers Nationwide is that
other states find out that there's
administrative hearing and so
um then that their other states may
start taking action and so this the
licensee is
asserting we need to resolve this right
away because I just need to wrap this up
okay any other questions from team
members
same very thank you very much thank you
is there anybody else would like to
testify in House Bill 479
speak now forevermore hold your peace
okay you want to call us public hearing
Edwards
foreign
so uh thank you Mr chair I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31. uh that's a
combination of Auburn Candia
Chester and Deerfield I'm here today to
introduce house bill 130.
um this is uh this is a kind of a
companion bill
to House Bill 172 that we we talked
about last week my my co-sponsor Peter
leishman was not able to be here today
otherwise he would have uh I really
valued his uh his testimony last week on
172 and would encourage you that you you
consult his testimony of as as though it
was also on HP 130 because everything he
said is still the case the distinction
between 130 and 172 is that
um
172 essentially said uh let's let's take
a pause and take a look at uh redundancy
issues and make sure that we're doing
the best that we can for our taxpayers
before we Levy a new tax
and this is uh kind of the the harder
end of it which is to say let's just
repeal the prescription drug
affordability board outright and I
wanted to do this to give the give some
clarity to what decisions are before us
and what the motivations are and and
give the committee an opportunity to
decide you know which which is a
preferable way to go
um I uh I could see just repealing it
outright for much of the reasons I I
said last week and I'll I'll hit some
high points there that I think uh need
to be hit because
um I think in subsequent testimony that
day some things that were said and
implied
uh who were not accurate and so I want
to make sure that um that you all have
heard that
I think one of the things I need to do
is to tell you a little bit about who I
am and my motivations for this bill I
I'm a I'm a 33 and a third year that's a
a third of a century as an Army Medical
Services Corps officer
my job for those years decades was to
conserve the fighting strength I did a
lot of operations planning I did a lot
of budget and Manpower work I did a lot
of I.T work I sort of did a lot of
things but in all of it my job was to
conserve the fighting strength figure
out what we could do to make our
operations as lean and mean and as
effective as possible and so when I
returned retired from the military and
from my job as a medical device
manufacturer program manager I came to
the house with that same training and
experience and motivation that I just
want things to work better
um I'm not a tool of the industry
uh despite any implications I'm not
submitting this for the industry I'm
submitting this for the citizens of
Auburn candy at Chester and Deerfield so
that when the state if the state starts
to issue new tax bills we've done our
due diligence to me this is about due
diligence as a business process
re-engineering subject matter expert I
have had experience taking a look at
multiple
processes and systems and trying to work
with others to rationalize the best way
to get things done and I see
this prescription drug affordability
board as an opportunity for us to do
some analysis to make sure that we
accomplish the objective which is to
create an environment where we can use
information power to put pressure
downward pressure on drug prices we all
agree on the intent
we all agree on the intent we all agree
on the intent we we just see a different
way of getting there this is a
bipartisan bill I'll note you know that
bipartisan doesn't mean unanimous
so
um so this is not a unanimous view but
it's certainly a bipartisan view that we
we might be able to do this better and
in your testimony last week you heard
essentially one of the witnesses say
that there is no redundancy
because no one has this mission
but if you go back and you listen to
what representative leishman and I were
saying is that there is some level of
redundancy there's some level of
redundancy in the way the fees are
assessed there's some level of
redundancy around the way the data is
collected there's some redundancy around
the reporting it it's it's not a
complete
synchronization of a Venn diagram but on
a Venn diagram there's a whole lot of
overlap that just needs to be
deconflicted and rationalized and so so
when you hear there is no redundancy
because the mission is unique that's not
the point the the point is that we want
to accomplish the mission but we want to
do it efficiently and effectively and
there's current redundancy now that's uh
that bearish look being looked at
we also said that this bill
is uh not the bill rather but um the
was first passed as part of a Christmas
tree Omnibus kind of piece of
legislation that is a true statement
okay what was also said by
representative leishman and myself is
that
the prescription drug affordability
board
never went through a normal house
process it did it did not go to ways and
means to look at the the tax
implications
the the the the the
proponents of the board prefer to call
it a fee assessment I I think if the
Ways and Means Committee heard it as a
former member of the Ways and Means
Committee I think many of them most of
them would think that it's a tax not a
fee and but the ways and means has never
been afforded an opportunity to look at
the affordability board
um also division three which I know a
little bit about is the current chair
and the chair from last term uh never
saw this bill so so on one hand Ways and
Means didn't look at the revenues
division three didn't look at the
expenses and so when we say to you that
that the drug affordability board never
went through the ordinary house process
that is literally a true statement and
to say otherwise I think
obfuscates out
so so Mr chair if I if I could I I'd
like just a couple more minutes
um it's just your discretion I think I
told you six minutes and it feels like
I'm approaching six minutes
um so I want to give you some some real
world examples of where we have some
redundancies and I can forward this
document to you later but this is to
substantiate that there are some
redundancies
if you look at RSA 420 golf colon 11a
uh what that does is it establishes a
statute for the New Hampshire
Comprehensive Health Information System
as being an all-payer claims database so
a lot of the data that the affordability
board would like to look at
already resides to some extent in an
existing database that was chartered and
already in statute
then we have an existing health care
cost website that the the Deputy
Commissioner of Insurance
Mr Bettencourt testified to last time
said it was it was temporarily available
but that there is a New Hampshire
prescription drug pricing on that
website and and and much of what the
magic of the drug affordability board is
intended to be if you assume that their
theory is correct they'll be able to
create a very powerful piece of
reporting and information that's unique
that will give people who already have
an incentive to reduce prices yet more
incentive to reduce prices so so we have
some of that reporting already
we we also have an annual report from
the health insurance on cost drivers
and that's been annual like I'm going to
afford this document to you later but
it's um it it it's got some specifics in
there where you could look it up
and then
we have a statute that requires it's RSA
318 colon 68 the high cost prescription
drug data so if there's a new drug
that's introduced that's defined to be
high cost
we require reporting on it and then
there's there's transparency to the
public
and then finally in terms of what are we
doing at the state level to try to
reduce prices
the Mr arlinghaus over the Das has
reverse PBM
auctions and there's a website I can
I'll share with you on that but it's but
the note I have here is that the Das is
currently conducts a reverse PBM auction
process for prescription benefits
provided to State Employees and retirees
according to das this is competitive
Marketplace Marketplace is helping to
hold the line on prescription drug
prices for the population so at the
state level I just I just read five
areas specifically where there's some
redundancy I didn't even get into the
federal areas because the federal
government has been trying to wrap their
hands on this for a while now and hasn't
been any more successful and as much as
I respect the individuals on the New
Hampshire prescription drug
affordability board they are very
willing to take on a a task that has
failed the federal government in Maine
so far that have more resources
moreheads start and and I would like to
believe that New Hampshire is just so
great we could accomplish their goal but
there's there's scant reason beyond
belief in those individuals that it will
get done we heard testimony last time
that the paragraph that tells them what
they're supposed to do is so
incomprehensible that it became the
subject matter of a joke in the pbap
meeting and and although the joke was
offensive to the person who told it it
was nevertheless true that the the the
the requirements of the report are are
so convoluted that it it it's probably
going to take years of analysis to even
figure out what it means
so so I would ask you to consider House
Bill 130 while you consider House Bill
172 one is just shut it down and let's
take a fresh look at this the other was
you know and our our attempt to be
reasonable and say hey let's just have a
good thorough discussion let's do the
right thing before we go plunging into
this and um I I think whatever wherever
the committee goes between that range of
two things I'm perfectly fine with I'm
here to answer any questions that you
great do we have questions yeah
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman I actually have
two questions
one is just sort of a definitional thing
that I as a resident of New Hampshire
don't understand myself which is what is
the definition of a fee versus tax
you're saying they're calling it a fee
but it's really a tax so what would be
like the the difference
so would you believe there actually is a
definitional distinction and that the
people in the ways and means deal with
that definition all the time I have it
somewhere in my email but so so without
being precise if they'll allow me to
tell you
generically what what the distinction is
is that is that when we pay a fee
the idea is that we are paying money to
help provide a government service in a
way that's relatively direct so that we
receive the benefit of that government
service so there's a a direct connection
between our payment of the money and the
resourcing of the government to be able
to to provide an environment or provide
the specific purpose or or goals to us
I'll give you as an example a marriage
license when you go and buy a marriage
license you're paying a marriage license
fee well you you could call that a tax
but we don't we call that a fee because
you're paying for the right to have your
your civil union recognized by the state
and to receive all the legal benefits of
marriage so that's a fee what's a tax
well a tax is the government
taking money to support General
operations that do not have a direct
benefit to the taxpayer
it's more of an indirect benefit like
for example
um we we pay taxes that go into the
highway trust fund and uh and that's
that's a tax because it it's going to
pay for the overall maintenance of the
road and although we get the benefit of
the environment we're not getting a
direct benefit
a toll on the other hand would be more
like a fee I understand uh for the
question for the question may inquire
okay and then so just on the redundancy
you you listed like I think you said
five different areas where there's three
different areas where there's some
redundancy I'm just kind of curious I'm
kind of thinking of it in the model of
like say maybe a general contractor does
it make sense to have maybe this board I
don't know anything about this I'm truly
just asking I don't have an opinion at
this point but what happens if you have
a general contractor building a house
you have them sort of managing plumbers
electricians Carpenters could it be kind
of like that where everything's in-house
and it's just more efficient
organization that way versus one person
doing one little bit of this redundancy
another person do another thing in which
case maybe it's actually a less
efficient way to get the desired outcome
okay so thank you for the question and
and my first general answer is yes it
could be that way but that is a
different answer than what is it now the
the P the prescription drug
affordability board as constituted in
law is really a stove pipe that isn't
integrated with other aspects of these
tasks that we're doing and oh you're
right there were five of them there were
three bullets but there were five
specifics so you were right but but
anyways
um
they're not chartered to be that
integration function they're chartered
to do a stove pipe function and in doing
the stovepipe function they're
replicating some activities that are
already being done elsewhere in statute
and and so that's where a small group of
you know experienced people uh could get
together in a few workshops really pound
out you know a more of a game plan on on
on
what already exists and how it could be
leveraged
um I I've I've spent maybe five hours on
it and I I think I have some ideas but
that's no substitute for you know having
the people who own the responsibility
and the executive branch really really
look at it and figure out what's what's
uh representative Terry yes
representative Edwards uh you and
representative leishman
brought us a bill last week where you
were advocating for a pause this week
we're dealing with the bill that where
you're advocating for for termination
if in fact you and your colleague
believe that the the board should be
terminated then what is the rationale
for bringing us a bill
to pause rather than to terminate
is it political so no
well let me say with disdain no no no
the the the issue is I'm not a member of
the Commerce Committee excuse me I I
don't have the experience that the
membership of this Commerce Committee
has what what I'm what I'm saying is
we've identified a problem and we we
need to fix this problem and to you the
Commerce Committee I'm saying hey look
there's there's a range of options here
there's a range to just shut it down and
try to get it right from from a fresh
start and then there's the option of
saying look let's let's have a
methodical conversation that's
disciplined by the statute so that we
can have the investigation and come back
with ideas on how to harmonize and
synergize these activities and so it's
really the once I submit the bills it's
really at the pleasure of this committee
what you want to do with it and I and I
think I said in my earlier testimony
today and and last week I'm giving you
this these two ideas so that you have a
range of options for you to exercise
your legislative discretion and decide
Paul for the question may inquire thank
you
first I did not I mean to suggest and I
hope that you did not miss the
understand uh that by using the word
political I meant something nefarious I
was speaking to the the matter of which
one perhaps was more feasible in your
view and and that of your co-sponsor but
uh that now having been clarified I hope
uh let me ask you uh if given your
druthers which of the two do you and
your colleague if you are able to speak
for him do you uh prefer
um which would I prefer between the two
I would prefer never to use the word
political because I considered a dirty
term you know I I'm talking about policy
options that's where I'm at but between
the two bills uh I I I was I was feeling
really good about 172 until I heard
subsequent testimony kind of got me
angry and you know as you've seen a
little hint of that you know uh and I
just burn it down kill it you know but
but that's my emotional reaction
what you guys do your seasoned mature
group of people you're going to figure
out which is the best of these two
Alternatives I think I I it was said in
testimony by others last week that there
had been discussions on this
as though those discussions Were Meant
to resolve all the differences what the
discussions did was highlight
fundamental differences between the
members of the current prescription drug
affordability board and what I think is
a more widespread holistic view of the
state as a system of systems and and and
we weren't going to resolve that
difference in discussions so this is how
we do things we bring you policy options
give you testimony and rely on you to
you know be the smart people great thank
you yes sir okay so uh representative
Gibbs thank you
uh representative Edwards um
you mentioned
um uh you listed actually a number of
items um that are already ongoing uh in
currently existing uh New Hampshire
agencies and under currently existing uh
law other than the uh this this board
and the law that established it
um you haven't said uh that everything
that the board uh proposes to do is
redundant
um and also
um uh
you said that the board is established
to act in a stovepipe function rather
than collaborating with all these other
agencies uh which I agree they they do
exist and they they do their various
functions uh but as I understood the
testimony by the members of the board at
the last Hearing in fact they are
Consulting with those other agencies and
they are working with them uh to obtain
the information in the most efficient
manner
so my question is uh isn't it worthwhile
to have an agency that can pull all of
this information together in an
efficient manner so as to make the best
recommendation to address the problems
of the high cost of prescription drugs
for New Hampshire Public payers
thank you for the question
um on on the issue of whether or not I
was completing my testimony that there
while I state that there are
redundancies I also sent you an email to
the committee maybe two hours ago and in
my write-up I specifically pointed out
that there were unique aspects to the
board as well
um that
should should still be in play but that
but that what our objective ought to be
is is uh to to identify those
redundancies and and to try to eliminate
them particularly when a new tax is
involved so for all of you people who've
been saying no taxes no new taxes this
is this is kind of stepping on that
um all right on the stove pipe issue I I
would point out that in testimony the
chair of the of the pdab
essentially in quotes said there is no
redundancy because the missions are
different and I'm challenging that to
say there are in fact redundancies and
if there's anyone who's been incomplete
or inaccurate it's not me you know there
are some redundancy and then and and
then in your question you you say that
wouldn't it be great if if they would
just look at all the information and
come back with with a better way of
doing this
and so you're assuming that they'll look
at all the information that's way beyond
their statutory Authority and my
experience with government is is when
you any bureaucracy this happened at
Phillips Medical Systems it happened you
know in the Army just you know anywhere
once you establish a new entity
the first and foremost goal of that
entity is to self-perpetuate and to grow
so so asking that entity to then
deconstruct itself if if that was the
smart thing to do and to delegate
Authority elsewhere
you know you're just asking a lot of a
government entity we just they just
don't people don't behave that way so so
that's why I'm saying let's call a
Timeout on that and let's put this other
group together whose job is to look
across the Departments and and figure
out a systemic way to approach us
follow-up question uh certainly thank
given the fact that this agency has been
established for a really very short time
and up until now has had neither funding
nor staff doesn't it make sense to give
it a chance to get some funding
um which would not come out of the
general fund but would come out rather
from the prescription drug industry and
honestly I don't care whether you call
it a fee or a tax
but it would the agency in order to
operate has to have some funding and it
has to be able to hire some staff right
now you have volunteers who are
gathering this information as best they
can and at least as I understood the
sorry I'm I'm uh
you're going a little long yeah just
your question is should there be funding
no that's not my question okay my
question is shouldn't the agency have a
chance to proceed get the funding hire
the staff and then decide whether
they're doing their job when they can do
their job since at present really they
really can't do it because they don't
have funding and staff
I I I think in your question there's
sort of a a fair point in there
um uh I I still end up with a different
conclusion though uh and I I would say
they've been in operation for two and a
half years and in January of 22 maybe it
was February
um the uh the the board came to the
Joint fiscal committee asking for
funding and I don't know if you know
what the fiscal committee does but we're
in a habit of saying yes I think we say
yes you know like 95 97 of the time I
mean don't tell my constituents that
because that'll bug a bunch of them but
but we we are we're predisposed to
saying yes to to these things this is a
unique time where we tabled it because
we just thought it was premature and not
cooked and instinctively you know that's
when I started you know my ears perked
up and I thought and represented
policemans as well that that there you
know that there's some redundancy here
let's let's make sure that we we get
this right before we go forward and uh
and I already mentioned that uh the
first rule of thumb of any bureaucracy
government or otherwise is to grow
so uh so I don't think uh asking them to
get started is going to do much than to
give them the chance to grow
great thank you we're all set
I had two questions
may I make one comment uh no no we do
that in in the exact session we get to
make comments
and there will be a subcommittee you can
make lots of comments
um but I'm afraid this is a comment in
reference to what the uh that is
absolutely in particular to make
comments upon a person who's testifying
is totally inappropriate and it is not
upon the person it doesn't matter
it's just you're you're it has the
feeling that you're hurt you're aiming
it towards the person because you just
have a question
thank you very much
thank you Mr chair and to any Committee
Member I I love to talk about this stuff
if you if you want to talk to me about
this offline I'm I'm happy to do it so
you can give him a call all right uh
chair calls on representative Gary
Merchant
thank you Mr chair before I get into my
testimony I'd like to be sure you have
the documents in front of you there's
one it's my written testimony
there's another one talks about total
gross expenditures which two lines that
third one is
transparency and affordability by Ela
litty on
gimlog
the fourth one is the recommendations
from the main board
and the fifth one is the language in the
do they want to have a copy of the
statute language for the represent
if you have all the documents then I
would like to proceed
fair enough fair enough
so good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the House congresson
consumer affairs committee and members
of the public
for the record my name is Gary Merchant
representing Sullivan County district 6
which is Clairemont and Croydon
I also chair the prescription drug
affordability board
I come before you today to oppose House
Bill 130. shall repeal RSA 126 BB
which is the prescription drug
affordability statute
prior to serving
in the state house I served on New
Hampshire to board a pharmacy for 10
years the last two years as a board
president
during my 40 plus years as a pharmacist
I spent my career
trying to understand the black box and
probably have a better understanding of
most people in this room
but it's complex it's convoluted
it's not transparent it doesn't work the
I gave you a diagram yesterday the last
time on House Bill 172 which deals with
the pharmacy supply chain the movement
of the product as well as movement of
the dollar
they're related
but they don't follow each other
your primary concern for the citizens
especially those elderly
many abandoned abandoned the drugs
because they can't afford it which only
leads to higher medical costs
the first report I want you to look at
which I think is fascinating this is
coming from the Berkeley group the one
with the two lines on it
back in 2013
Pharma claimed about 67 percent of gross
expenditures for prescription drugs
if you look at the next one which is
from Eli Lilly
what you'll see on that one
is back in 2016
the list price of the drug was 246
dollars
the net price that they actually
received was 59.
yet in 2020
the list price was 275 dollars but the
net to Lily went down to 50.
when you do the math what you'll find
out quickly is a list price went up by
over 14 percent
but the Nets of the company
so I asked this committee to funnel them
out the question
what is going on
why are drugs paid by the patients
increasing well net prices to the
pharmaceutical manufacturers are
decreasing
where is the money going
who benefits from the lack of
transparency and abolishing the
I think we all can agree that openness
and transparency are essential
components
for fully functioning democracies
and to sustain a market economy
built upon the free market
in 2020 the legislature created RSA 26
BB to establish the board a primary goal
of the legislation was until this is to
provide greater transparency to a
non-transparent pricing system that will
ensure that state and other public
payers optimize the opportunity
for savings on prescription drugs to
I wish to address a few issues in
regards to the last meeting we had on
House Bill 172.
there was discussion about having the
ability to get into the rebates and the
insurance department does it well they
do it at the aggregated level what they
don't do is that the drug level
RSA and it's in your packet
look at the line it's underlined does
give the board the authority on specific
drugs to get into where is the money
going who's getting the rebates who's
getting the fees to begin to understand
it
number two
there was a comment that the main board
has been around and hasn't done a thing
before you our four recommendations from
the main board that they put together
number three the board will use
current data in chis which is the
all-pair claims plus any other available
data so we're not recreating another
and as far as the hearing goes
last year
this house heard House Bill 150 1566
which also introduced to repeal the
board
the house executive department of
administrations heard and deliberated on
that bill
it came out unanimously 19-0
with a vote for interim study
on the other side of the wall
we had Senate Bill 450
which at that time was Senator Sherman
sponsored to make some technical
corrections to how to the RSA
and to give you an example of certain
things that happen you talk about
redundancy the New Hampshire attorney
general settled the case with centene
Medicaid managed care provider for over
21 million dollars
read my lips 21 million dollars
for incorrect pricing of Medicaid
prescriptions
same thing happened in Ohio for 88
million
I'll bring this to your attention as
well
when the bill passed
to establish the board our governor
governor cenino
released the following statement I'll
read a steal quote this bill will create
a drug affordability board in New
Hampshire to monitor changes
in the cost of prescription drugs to
keep the industry honest
and to keep an eye on prices to prevent
price spikes often many challenges in
healthcare can start to be addressed
through greater transparency in pricing
that transparency begins scrutiny and
accountability as to why the cost of a
particular drug is higher or higher than
similar drugs
in my closing
their Journey from the manufacturer to a
patient passes through many entities
via a complicated
complex
non-transparent path
often to the detriment of the patient
and public payers a primary goal the
prescription drug affordability board is
to bring greater transparency
on pricing of prescription drugs to
ensure the state of New Hampshire and
other public payers save valuable Health
Care dollars both for the government and
for the taxpayer
so my question is if you're this part
that's underlined here correct says that
they must give you this information
and since this law has been on the books
for
two and a half years or two years have
you gotten any information from them
have they actually told you the dollar
amounts of all rebates and fees
concerning drugs collect have have the
have they given you that information
before we get into that let me go back
to a little bit of history of the board
when the board was created
we didn't have a funding mechanism as
far as out took paper expenses we get
staff and so forth to accomplish exactly
what you're looking for Mr chairman hunt
we then ran into the issue with joint
fiscal committee the two sponsors of
this bill were on that committee opposed
us getting funding for the board
I repeat they opposed us getting funding
for the board and tabled the request so
when he talks about 95 of the requests
going through it did include ours
so then we finally got through with
Senator Sherman at the time to make the
technical correction to allow the board
to have a non-lapsing fund to fund the
board
then we got into rulemaking
in rulemaking was a slugfest it was very
difficult to get the rules through
because of many oppositions along the
way
so for the last two and a half years we
both
try to figure out how to get funded we
had to
take back or push back the fuel and
house bill
1566 which is going to repeal the board
we had to go through rule making process
we're finally at the point now that we
have things in place to hopefully get
the staff and start asking the questions
you're asking for so but I I don't see
anything here in the sentence about
staff all I see here is that the board
which is evidently volunteer all they
have to do is have a specific perception
drug and which those were provided
pursuance
debt that that you have the right the
legal right to have pbms and insurance
companies to tell you what those rebates
are and fees you don't need a board you
don't need a committee you don't need
anybody the board has this statutory
yes please
um so for the record my name is Tom
Sherman I'm a former state senator and I
sit on the board but I'm speaking for
myself as a citizen of New Hampshire
to answer your question
we need an infrastructure in place both
to accept that data so if we ask that
question much of what's coming in is
proprietary
so having a confidential database that
that can go into that took more than six
to eight months
there is oversight that requires a
certain amount of
um
overhead and that's where having an
executive director and an administrative
assistant which is what we determined
would be the least amount of staff that
we would need to be able to accept that
data make sure it's appropriately
managed
um
we are administratively attached to the
Department of Health and Human Services
but we are independent so we don't
utilize
their staff with that function that
you're describing we have to have our
own staff we do utilize
their channels of accepting data because
it is proven confidential
and finally just to go back to the
fiscal committee one of the requests
that they had that prompted the tabling
is that we didn't have rules in place
yet so we weren't going to get funded
unless we had rules in place so that's
where we pivoted
last February and March to go back and
really focus on rules and so once we had
rules and once we had SB 450 in place we
now have the infrastructure as a board
to move forward and do the work the
actual work of the board rather than
creating the infrastructure so I'm
confused because I keep seeing stuff
here about confidentiality yep so
how why would they tell you anything
you're out just because they have a law
here that says they have to you they
sure share it with you they also have a
law that have protect their
confidentiality
so if you get a piece of paper that's
blacked out everything's blacked out
because it's confidential then you
haven't gotten anything you don't need a
you don't need an executive director you
don't need a department a bunch of
people to tell you that we this is
useless information because it's all
confidential no that's not actually the
role of the board the the board would be
able to accept the confident
confidential information do the analysis
on it and then present de aggregated I'm
sorry aggregated de-identified
information to the public it's not
something that
we are designed to accept
highly confidential information from
all different levels of people who are
required to send data to us
say that again are you or are you not
requiring Insurance com insurance
company and bbms and manufacturers to
disclose confidential information to you
okay
and that's that's what we do I've been a
physician for 35 years
we are used to working in a confidential
environment
uh that's the way the Department of
Health and Human Services operates they
are used to working in an environment
that provides confidentiality and by the
way the penalties for a breach of
confidentiality are severe in this bill
the problem I have is what you're
looking for is this for instance as a
doctor you have a contract with a
insurance company
right that's confidential right
nobody you're not supposed to share you
are borrowed from sharing it an
insurance company is better to share
that information
but but that's not what we're asking for
that we can't ask for that that's
exactly what you're asking no you're
asking we're not asking for a contract
between an insurance company and a
physician no you're asking for what the
fees were paid what the rebates were
isn't that what the contracts are for
prescription drugs not for
Medical Services right but it's the
exact same thing at the end of the day
the end of the day
what you're looking for is confidential
you want to know what were the rebates
what were the Kickbacks what were the
things that we don't see between the
insurance company the pbms and the
pharmaceutical people and the
Distributors you're saying is
transparency we want to see how much
money was transparent how much money was
sent back and forth
but that's based on a contract that in
the nature of that contract is
confidentiality
that's their secret formula isn't that
true
care is being argumentative and not
asking questions
fair enough I'll I will back off you
don't have to answer it the question is
there
okay can I also talk about the issue of
the board funding itself this does not
go through the general fund it's outside
of it so we're not taxing the taxpayer
um I agree with representative Gibbs
with its attacks if he will call what
you want it's outside of the general
fund and therefore when you talk about
it going to Ways and Means of going to
the fiscal committee and so forth that
deals with the general fund this is
outside of that
so just remember that in that context as
well
um part of the whole thing is if we
begin to understand
what's happening in the marketplace
the goal of the board is to create
strategies to help the public payers
reduce the overall cost
Maine has done that they came back with
some recommendations
I think would like to build on
as the board there are ways to help
people if you begin to understand the
marketplace
it's like I said before it's complex
it's convoluted and it's not
straightforward but having people
who really take the time including the
board to understand it the goal is to
help people become better buyers of
prescription drugs so they can save the
taxpayer dollar
foreign
well this is awkward because we got
people want to ask questions and then
you want to testify again so we got to
get to the chase okay representative
purcelli
sure I understand the funding so we're
funding mechanism
sure thank you
the funding mechanism is what they call
assessment fees it's fees lebudon to the
individuals of the entities within the
pharmacy supply chain
so that's how the board is being funded
it's not coming from funds from the
general
fund which is taxpayer dollars
for the question you may inquire could
that potentially increase the cost of
the drugs or premium insurance premiums
well when you consider the fact that the
prescriptions in the U.S is a half a
billion dollars and you look at
something may cost 500 000 to run the
board
I guess you could possibly look at it as
a intimate intestinal amount to the fee
but same time what you need to think
about is how much money can we save
because if we can save the taxpayers
more than five hundred thousand dollars
I'm sure we will
an assessment by the way are running
between 500 to a thousand dollars on a
company it's multi-million dollars
okay representative Burroughs
thank you thank you for taking my
question and thank you for saying that
this is convoluted because my head is
spinning
um what I'd I'd like to understand is I
mean I've heard testimony that you can't
get the confidential data that you need
and you can and I don't I don't feel
like um I didn't feel like we got an
answer and and I'd like to hear it from
your perspective
short of it yes
we can if you look at the statute we can
require the information to be sent to
the board again back to what Dr Sherman
said
the information we're asking for is
confidential
and because of the nature we wanted to
be sure the manufacturers or anyone else
submitting that information to the board
is protected with that confidential
information so the consequence that
anyone who
has access to the information and
releases it is a criminal offense it's
taken seriously there's only a handful
of people can actually get to the data
so answer your question yes we can
receive it we can ask for it and receive
it
further questions are you receiving it
now or you can't because you don't have
the uh staff in the infrastructure we
don't have the staff and the
infrastructure and no manufacturer is
going to send us information that's
confidential if we don't have a process
in place to protect it and we can't put
the process in place to protect it we
don't have to snap
I've had top secret clearances with the
military for 53 years
I understand the notion of
confidentiality really really well
if you sign an NDA that is acceptable to
the PDM
and you provide a database
that has the proper security
are you allowed to use the data then get
the data not redacted but get the data
that you're asking for as long as you
have that NDA and a proper storage
location are you then allowed to you get
the data use the data
aggregate the data come out with
conclusions and the conclusions do not
violate the NDA
then are you set up to do what you need
to do
yes
and if I may that's not the only
database that we would be using
some of the earlier testimony today
talked about what was called
redundancies I would say it's resources
that are available already so we don't
have to recreate them which is database
there's database at UNH database at
Dartmouth
database and these are
large databases that look at New
Hampshire
they are in different places not all in
the department of insurance by the way
some are in HHS some are in universities
and so
the benefit of the board which does not
exist right now
is the ability to pull these databases
and actually answer questions
so that we can
put together strategies moving forward
on how to lower cost for the taxpayers
on prescription drugs if you don't
do this
the Black Box stays in place
nobody knows
what's happening
um
if I could I also wanted to mention
again as I mentioned last week
that reverse auction is one tool
I co-sponsored that bill
it was in that Christmas tree bill
it has not been repealed because it's
working
and it's working because it was able to
so I just want to make sure people
understand what the reverse auction
does not in detail but recognize that
this is all a part of a package of bills
that we did back in 2020 together
strongly bipartisan in fact it remains
strongly bipartisan
um to do everything we possibly can to
lift the veil off of prescription drug
pricing not violating proprietary
information but using a tool to
understand why
prescriptions drug prescription drugs
are costing so much
and not prices but cost
and how we can bring that cost down
without this bill we continue forward in
the way we're doing
no centralized
place to coalesce the information
no place to I'm a gastroenterologist
digest it
and I won't go any further with how we
regurgitate it but the bottom line is we
need this board as a tool and you know I
have yet to find a bill in my four terms
in the legislature that's perfect
and if there need to be changes along
the way
let's make the changes but let's not
throw out the baby with the bath water
and leave us as ignorant as we are right
now about why prescription drugs are
costing us so much in the state of New
Hampshire and by the way
I think we do things better than the
United States of America in a lot of
ways we're smaller
we know each other at every different
level of the government we can ask
questions of each other maybe we just
could come to an answer
that the that Congress can't
I think that's possible
representative Gibbs
thank you uh in order to request
receive uh
properly maintain Aggregate and analyze
the data that you need in order to
fulfill the board's statutory
responsibilities is it necessary for the
yes yes thank you
representative Terry
well curiously and interestingly
following on representative Gibbs
question I'm looking at the handout that
you provided from the state of Maine I'm
curious to know if you know and would
you if you do would you please disclose
or otherwise secure the information for
me and the members of the committee
is the main under the main statute is
the main pdab
uh supported by paid staff
uh what are the positions
um and how is the main pdab uh funded
representative Terry if I may there's a
representative here today from the main
board
Jennifer Rick and I think you may want
to hold that question for her
so you you don't know and you prefer
that I asked the domain he knows the
details I do not thank you
representative Airman
thank you Mr chair thank you for
testifying before us and taking all
these questions I'm looking at your most
recent report for The Advisory Board
2022. I just have some questions
um so the the gist of the report it
looks like five pages
uh you talk about the data that you're
uh you referenced earlier and some of
the limitations of that data you
identify the top 25 most prescribed
drugs and ones with cost increases so
I'm just kind of restating uh rehashing
what your report said but your goals for
this coming year uh it includes
something finalized the mou with DHHS
and uh could you explain what still
needs to be finalized with DHHS sure
thank you
I'm not sure which RSA it is but when a
board's Ministry look attached to an
agency there has to be an mou between
the the board if you will and the
oversight which is DHHS here so the mou
basically is defining what the
responsibilities are in both parties
what the cost is going to be how
one party's paying the other party for
resources they take or use so that's the
whole mou between the board and the
department of health Team and services
we are now in the process of finalizing
that hopefully next Tuesday we can come
to conclusion on the mou we've been
working with
uh the finance people trying to
understand what the costs are that
they're going to incur because of our
staff
that's what it's for for the question
thank you why has it taken uh looks like
almost 18 months to establish the mou
with the dhhsi why such a long process
We have basically volunteers on the
board that have generously donated some
of their time we don't have paid staff
we don't have someone sit down and write
things and work through it that way it
comes back to a resource constraint
so we had to get through trying to
defend the bill the board last year we
worked on the rules we worked on a joint
fiscal we've had many things in our
plate and the mou was probably one of
the things you wanted to work towards
which we're getting to on that list
correct
and I would just add that the mou is
somewhat directed by the rules so
the rules it's it's all cart or horse
and in this case the rules had to come
in place before fiscal would look at
money that we ended up not needing
because we now have our own way of our
own means for generating revenue for
not Revenue operating
uh
uh the money we need to do to operate
second of all we needed
rules we can't do an mou without knowing
I would like to add the department has
been phenomenally supportive though
throughout so
hats off to them and their willingness
to work with us
chair will call on David roguefort
representative reprod who is in
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I was here two weeks ago and
promised you I wouldn't be back and I
want to apologize for being back here
this is not a pharmacy issue it's more
or less a prescription obviously a
prescription drug issue
um
I'm a pharmacist and I currently serve
on the New Hampshire Board of Pharmacy
but I just wanted to stop in today and
metered opposition to to this bill and I
say metered opposition because anytime I
hear the word executive director and
administrative staff a radar goes up and
you know I think that we've all been
around this institution long enough to
understand the uh the dangers and
potential for bureaucratic creep and
um you know it's it's
oftentimes I think we're compelled to do
things and take action because we think
it might be the right thing to do and
many times those those things that we do
become institutionalized and
I am absolutely opposed to
institutionalized bureaucracy however
I was here two weeks ago to talk about
prescription drug pricing and I think
from my testimony there uh you should
have probably understood the
complexities of it we talked about Mac
pricing we talked about different types
of uh pricing structures the chairman
um gave us some insight into things like
any willing provider and uh and and many
of the the the the effects that are on
this this system and again it's a
complex system it's a system that we as
taxpayers in the state of New Hampshire
are ultimately paying for in our in our
taxes
um
just to give an illustration of that
there's a drug called Remicade that's
available and remicates a drug that me
as a pharmacist I can buy a wholesaler
for twelve hundred dollars for one vial
of that I know in my district I could go
to one facility and have that infused
for five thousand dollars I could go to
another facility within my district to
have that infused for thirty thousand
dollars so why is it that a twelve
hundred dollar drug could cost
a wildly different prices on our system
um it could be contract that could very
well be that that certain certain as
part of an alien willing provider
agreement agreed to do that it could be
other things but I think that this board
the intention of this board uh I hope
would unveil some of that stuff
um
and I say I hope because I this is
obviously a relatively new board and
we've heard today some of the struggles
and obstacles that they've had just
operating within the bureaucracy they're
trying to operate the bureaucracy
themselves so my suggestion I think that
at this point we all understand this
board's been put on notice uh I would
like to see the board have a fairly
short leash to deliver results with a
certain period of time my recommendation
would to be to to give them a little
latitude to deliver results if they
can't give us results and actionable
items to decrease drug prices in the
state of New Hampshire I'll be the first
one to sign on to that bill to cancel
this board but I think it's Hasty at
this point I think we're a little
premature so that's why I I would ask
that you oppose uh 130.
so the one of the contentions is that we
want transparency and so therefore we
can lower drug prices
so what in your mind you think they're
going to find in transparency that will
help us actually lower drug prices my
opinion I'm going to give you my opinion
this is Dave's opinion I think that
there's uh so let me give you let me let
me give you an example of this so and
then and then I can expound on that a
little bit so uh anecdotal I have a
friend who worked for a drug company
down in Florida they they came up with a
delivery system that would deliver a
hormone drug that was typically
available in a cream in a capsule it was
something that would be inserted in a
capsule it is wildly popular people
using creams you know they're messy
they're hard to use this thing would
have really changed a lot of the way
this particular drug was was delivered
the drug itself costs 20 cents the
packaging costs a dollar eighty I
believe so it's a two dollar drug that
the actual cause but they spent millions
of dollars researching the drug they've
spent they had to go through the drug
approval process to bring it to Market
they did a lot of focus group studies
and they realized that a drug this
particular drug would have they would
have a market for it to Market it at
ninety dollars a month
um the the women that they they
interviewed felt that was a fair
reasonable price it was something that
even Insurance wouldn't cover they would
be able to cover the ninety dollars well
this is a New Drug Company they'd never
launched a drug to Market before so as
they started you know they have the drug
ready to go it's it's it's made they've
got the drug the nearing the approval
process the finalization approval
process and as they started going to
wholesalers they wanted to cut that the
pbms want to cut of that the the uh the
switching companies the the various
other people wanted a Medicaid you know
Medicare they all wanted a piece of this
drug uh as it as it became on the market
so every time they had a fee they said
well yeah we'll we'll do that we'll make
sure we build it into the price so what
was what started as a 90 a month drug
ended up being about a 365 a month drug
and you know that was all of those
hidden fees that they didn't that they
didn't anticipate it was a you know
probably naiveness they probably should
have invested in some more experience uh
in their drug company but it added to
the cost so to answer your question I
think the commission the committee
hopefully would expose some of that so
you know as as taxpayers of people that
are paying Medicaid to provide drugs
I don't know about you but I don't think
I should be paying a kick back to a
wholesale company to keep it on their
shelves you know we want to make sure
that people have the drugs we shouldn't
be I don't believe funding Kickbacks I
say Kickbacks rebates incentives things
like that so that's part of the
transparency that's only part of the
transparency I think that we're about to
to find out
um and so I hope my my my
hope would be that's the kind of things
that we would see so we here in the
legislature could say no we're not going
to pay that much when we you know fund
our Medicaid we're only going to pay
this much
um you know I I believe the transparency
will ultimately let the free market work
because when things are hidden it's not
it's not a free market so but with that
I don't think a committee should be
languished and and they should be coming
back year after year after year saying
we're going to get some answers we're
going to get some answers we're going to
get some answers I think that there
should be a timeline I think that we
should have some actionable items within
you know a certain period of time
whatever that time is I'm not you know I
I don't want to speculate on that but
again if they can't deliver on what
they're promising now that they've got
all the the rules out of the way they've
fought through some of their early
bureaucratic bottles if they can't
deliver liver after now then or now now
they should be able to already hit the
ground running
um and let's set a timeline let's let's
let's make sure that they have some you
know some actionable items within a
period of time and like I said if they
can't do that then you know executive
director is an administrative uh staff
shouldn't be paid to tell us we're
almost there so I again I I support the
commission
but again temperate support I think that
we should you know we should set a
thank you very much thank you uh chair
we'll call on Jennifer wreck from
yes I think we um pronounce it Nash B uh
the National Academy for State Health
policy
so uh good afternoon uh chairman hunt
and members of the committee I am
Jennifer reck I am director of Nashville
Center on drug pricing in Portland Maine
I would like to clarify that I am also a
board member of Maine's prescription
drug affordability board
um and I'm happy to answer questions
about that however I'm here today
representing Nash B not the main board
um in case you're not familiar with Nash
B we're a nonpartisan organization that
works really closely with states to
develop and Implement Innovative State
Health policy Solutions we recognize
that state policy reflects the unique
situation of States however and so for
that reason we don't testify for or
against legislation so I'm here today
just to provide background information
and to help answer any questions if I
can
um we created our Center on drug pricing
in 2017 in response to hearing the need
from States for strategies to take on
drug pricing
and we have since developed model
legislation and provided technical
assistance to support legislators and
executive Brands officials trying to
address the high cost of drugs and when
bills are enacted we also support
implementation with technical assistance
so in 2017 Nash B released model
legislation for prescription drug
affordability board and since that time
Six States have enacted such boards
the pdabs as we call them
um in Maine and New Hampshire are
actually relatively unique amongst those
boards in terms of their approach that
approach being to set prescription drug
spending targets for public purchasers
and to make recommendations to enable
public purchasers to meet those targets
Nashville has been providing technical
assistance to the pdabs to the the
states implementing pdabs through a
contract with the program on regulation
Therapeutics and law at Harvard Medical
School in Brigham and Women's Hospital
we convene regular meetings so states
can benefit from their tax from their
technical expertise and share their
knowledge and experience
these convenings allow States like New
Hampshire to maximize use of their
resources through no cost technical
assistance and support
states are purchasers of prescription
drugs of course for state employees and
retiree Health Plans State hospitals
universities Corrections amongst others
and as drug costs spiral New Hampshire
of course still is required to balance
its budget
and the work of the prescription drug
ability affordability board
to set prescription drug spending
targets and to advance strategy to meet
those targets can help public purchasers
struggling with high cost drugs
nine states currently have set spending
targets for overall annual growth in
health care costs those benchmarks range
from 3.1 to
3.3.4 percent
and are largely designed to better align
Health Care spending growth with the
state's overall economic growth because
as we're all aware health care costs
tend to outpace other sectors and
aspects of the economy
um in lieu of the unsustainable growth
in prescription drug spending year over
year
a spending Target creates a guard rail
and can help and send public payers to
collaborate and develop policy Solutions
the pdab plays the role of setting the
appropriate targets and in supporting
payers by identifying strategies to meet
those spending targets can also offer
public purchasers a leg up in
negotiations offering them leverage when
they push back against unsustainable
growth and spending
importantly the pdab allows public
purchasers flexibility in how they would
meet those targets
um the pdub also enables the state to
better understand prescription drug
spending this is some of the
transparency aspects we've been
discussing and to identify specific
issues and cost drivers that can inform
thoughtful evidence-driven policy making
to achieve the common goal of clinically
appropriate responsibly controlled
prescription drug spending
and as you continue your work on this
bill Nashville would be happy to help
answer any questions that you may have
thank you for your time
thank you is uh my clerk would love to
have your written testimony uh yeah I
brought copies I'll share them yeah
great thank you very much we have
questions in the clinic where's
representative Terry so it sounds like
from your testimony and and your your
title your position that you would be
able to uh speak
to the question that I put
previously with respect to Maine to the
other States since you work with the
other states as well or you're at least
knowledgeable of those so I I am curious
for whatever you can tell me whatever
you can tell the committee as to how
under the uh how many states did you say
was it nine that happened Six States six
states that have paid ABS
um are they
um do they do they all have paid staff
or how many of them do how many of them
don't and
um and how are these pdabs funded in the
uh other of the Six States
so
um I'll start with New Hampshire of
course you're aware of and being as I
pointed out is
um similar in terms of its goals with
the new as as the New Hampshire pdab is
we also do not have any paid staff and
have been in operation for about two
years now
we will get some support through another
state office created the Office of
affordable health care which did
actually just yesterday announce an
executive director that they're bringing
on so the main pdab will be supported
through that office and through that
executive director though that person is
not dedicated solely to the main board
um in the other four states
um there are executive directors and
staff in Maryland
um Colorado and Oregon Washington passed
more recently and I believe that they
are searching for but haven't hired an
executive director yet
um and the funding models are similar to
New Hampshire's in terms of fees on drug
manufacturers and pbms and other
entities in the supply chain
so none of the five states are fund fund
therapy to Absolute General revenues but
through assessments I believe that is
correct I would have to triple check
every state but I would be very
surprised if there were General funding
I can I can check and confirm that thank
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you for coming from Maine uh to
testify
um I think one of the uh previous
speakers mentioned that the main pdab
came up with four recommendations is
that right so far
uh I believe that was representative
Merchant talking about recommendations
the New Hampshire board had made
although we have we have put out
um two annual reports that make
recommendations and you're you're on
that board yes correct could you give us
just a summary of those uh those four
recommendations or however many
recommendations there are um sure yeah
and I'd be happy to share the the
reports afterwards just in case I I'm
not remembering them all
um in last year's report which was our
initial report uh focused
um in large part on strategies that
public purchasers could take
um thank you
um so
um for example
um strategies that have already come up
like stronger
um Contracting with pbms through
approaches like uh reverse auctions
um but also delved into some specific
contract Provisions
um that would increase transparency and
make contracts more favorable for public
purchasers I believe we also addressed
the concept of waste free formularies
which is a review of drugs on the
formulary to make sure there are no
drugs on there that are essentially very
high cost without added clinical benefit
and there are some really egregious
examples of some drugs that are really
um
clinically equivalent for example like
some combined therapies will be
clinically equivalent to two much
cheaper drugs that would cost very
little if you bought them separately but
if you buy the combined agent may become
suddenly very costly so that's the kind
of example of a wasteful drug that
public purchasers can review their
formularies for
um I believe we also recommended
collaborative purchasing strategies
looking at ways to strengthen purchasing
power of public purchasers by combining
lives that are covered under various
plans to strengthen negotiating
positions and strategies along that
those lines and we also recommended some
legislative proposals
things that the the state could Advance
legislatively which could help reduce
prescription drug costs really more
across the board which would help public
purchasers as well of course so those
strategies included things like looking
at reference rates
so for example looking to Canadian
prices where drugs are much less costly
and looking to those for setting payment
rates for public purchasers in the state
in order to essentially capture savings
that might be available without having
to establish an importation program
thank you very much
thank you
good afternoon chairman hunt and and
committee members and thank you so much
for this opportunity to testify
um in very strong opposition to hb-130
um I don't have a lot to add uh you've
heard quite a lot of testimony already
from technical experts
um
and you know the ins and outs of the
prescription drug affordability board
and the law and the rules
um one thing that we haven't talked
about this this afternoon is how this
affects human beings and that was
something that I've been thinking about
as I've you know heard us go back and
forth about
um you know the technical pieces
um
so I moved back to New Hampshire to take
care of my dad who had Parkinson's
disease who since passed away and I was
in a Parkinson's support group
uh for caregivers and
um someone in that group couldn't afford
the Parkinson's medications and they had
to sell their house
um and move into Apartments so that they
could you know keep their husband alive
uh this morning I was at the doctor's
office and she told me that we were
talking about a prescription and she
told me that oh well you know what it's
very expensive but you know what a lot
of my patients drive to Canada to get
their drugs because it's only three
hours away and it's about a tenth of the
cost there
um and
also I live in Ossipee New Hampshire and
I won't of course mention this person's
name but I also know somebody who
uh someone in town who
um
had cancer and
um both the medication and the cost of
treatment he did not want this to be a
burden on his children
so he took his own life
and so while we're debating the ins and
outs and how much and
one of the reasons I love living in New
Hampshire is because we do have
accountability in government and we are
so judicious in how we spend money and I
think that's absolutely critical and
it's a very well-run State and and the
New Hampshire legislature does an
amazing job of keeping costs down
but the prescription drug affordability
board not only has you know the
possibility of
you know life-changing I mean we also at
AARP we collect a lot of stories from
um you know folks 55 and older and
um we also have a lot of people who are
struggling to afford their medication
they're literally trying to make the
decision do I eat or do I take my
medication do I heat my house
um so you know the prescription drug
affordability board
is a chance for
us to have the possibility of bringing
those drug prices down not only for
people who have worked for the New
Hampshire government but also for the
state and yes there is uh an investment
of hiring staff but I ask you to
consider the potential cost savings for
both the state and for our citizens
um and thank you so much for your time I
know this has been a very long hearing
thank you I have one card left Jake
good afternoon Mr chairman honorable
members of the committee so nice to see
you again again my name is Jake Berry
I'm the vice president of policy at new
Futures we're a non-partisan non-profit
Health policy and advocacy organization
I don't want to repeat too much of what
has been said uh this afternoon I don't
want to repeat too much of what I said
last week but I do want to stress our
strong opposition to this bill and our
support for the prescription drug
affordability board certainly as I said
last week we are not against looking
into redundancies we are not against
looking into efficiencies what we're
here to ask is that you keep the board
in place you do not suspend it you do
not repeal it that you allow it to
continue to do its critical important
work while you look into those matters
um as as genso uh put so articulately
there are people suffering in this state
there are people who are rationing their
medication who are not taking their
medication who are having to make
choices between uh home heat and and
medication and yet we're here talking
about doing away with a board that was
founded with the intent to help reduce
these uh to help reduce these costs it I
I find it somewhat bewildering
um so uh with that just know we ask you
to uh last thing you'll notice Senator
Sherman mentioned if there are ways that
you can see to improve this board they
would they would be all the years they
were glad to work on SB 450 last year to
strengthen the board to expand and to
expand his work uh and I'm sure they
would be glad to do so again but to uh
to suspend or repeal the board at this
point would uh to me seem misguided and
would really negatively impact the the
health of our state and with that I'm
thank you thank you uh I made a mistake
there was one card hiding here
from
Red's good okay thank you Donald
funstein Gallagher office ahip
two quick information points one
since 2005 New Hampshire has had this
Comprehensive Health Insurance system in
place
according to the HHS presentation before
the prescription drug board on June 25th
that system which has been in place
since 2005 includes no fewer than 22
data element fields on prescription
drugs including name of drugs codes of
drugs prescriber co-pays co-insurance
deductibles
Etc
uh I would encourage you to look at
appendix I to the
2021 report of the prescription drug
board and you'll see the entire
presentation from the young man at HHS
the second informational point is simply
the
New Hampshire Insurance Department's
most current Report on health
care Premium cost drivers dated October
prepared by the Gorman Actuarial firm
is based
in large measure maybe you almost
exclusively on this database that's been
in existence since 2005. and if you look
at that report you'll find it on the
department's website or certainly I can
give you a link at page 48
you'll specifically find in its the
reports treatment of prescription drugs
that the information reported throughout
the report is net
of rebates and that the rebates for
prescription drugs are paid by the
manufacturers to the insurers and go to
directly reduce the prescription cost
that go into the health care
so again you can find that at page 48
uh at the most recent report dated
October 18th those are the two
information points I wanted to share and
what does a hip oh yes a hip what
health insurance health insurance health
insurance insurance companies all the
insurance companies I work for Heidi
Kroll University I thought you were for
her for you
the information thank you the
information that you indicated that you
that is on that website were things like
deductibles and payments and all that
that stuff
is doesn't sound to me anything like the
kind of information
that the pdab wants to get a hold of
that's the so I'm asking the kind of
things that they are asking for seem to
be very different
uh do you why do you think that they're
the same because it doesn't seem to be
the same at all you know wholesale
prices Pharmacy prices Kickbacks to pdms
all that kind of stuff that's not what
you're listing as part of the insurance
database
uh thank you for the question
um I'm not sure I addressed that point
but
uh on that point
uh I referred you to page 48 of the New
Hampshire Insurance departments uh
report of October 18th where they talk
about the prescription drug data being
net of rebates
so there's some
information in the system somewhere
that confirms that the prices were
reported as net of rebate exactly what
big thank you thank you
oh
all right so uh the blue sheet
um not much any people who spoke uh
they're all in opposition to the bill
Karen
uh Miner dorsche the opposition Ben
Cotton Jan Weiss
and the last two testify with that we
mm-hmm
thank you so much yeah okay thank you
okay we'll open up the public hearing on
uh House Bill 249 and here from the
prime sponsor
Anita Burroughs oh thank you how many
borrowers that are Anita Burrows
representing Carol 2 and the prime
sponsor is um representative
um
Edwards Edwards and uh we'd like to be
known as The Odd Couple going forward
all right well you can go ahead you go
forward okay so
um I'm introducing
um HP 249 this is being done at the
request of the insurance company as I
said representative
as I said representative Edwards is the
prime sponsor
um this bill will adopt the National
Association of insurance Commissioners
model law to establish regulatory
standards for the pet insurance industry
some elements of the model law address
consumer protections pre-existing
conditions pet wellness programs and
training requirements for Insurance
Producers I also just want to add that
it was clarified to me that this isn't
the kind of this isn't health insurance
as we would think of a policy for itself
it's it's considered um proper more of a
property insurance although I would
argue that my dog owns me I don't own
him
[Music]
um
uh some elements of the model law
address uh consumer protections
pre-existing conditions pet wellness
programs and training requirements for
Insurance Producers
um Deputy Commissioner DJ Bettencourt is
here and he can give us some more
complete understanding of the bill um
you all said Jess
I I deferred because she's done more
homework on this bill and I figured by
now you'd be tired of me and unless
representative Terry wants to talk about
uh memory questions from the committee
members
so DJ
I was wondering why
box was sticking around I always bring
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is still DJ
Bettencourt and I still have the
pleasure of serving as the Deputy
Commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department I am joined this
afternoon by two of my colleagues James
Fox the head of our Property and
Casualty Division and Emily Doherty our
legal beagle for the Property and
Casualty department and we are excited
to talk with you this afternoon about
pet insurance in support of House Bill
249 which the sponsors correctly
indicated was at the request of the
department
in 1982 the first pet insurance policy
was sold in the United States
and it was issued to
Lassie
the television star yep it was issued to
Lassie which one whether there are four
of them uh 1982 I think that was
probably a uh a later version of Lassie
if you will but it was issued by the
Veterinary Pet Insurance Company
but since that time the pet insurance
industry has exploded the North American
Pet Health Insurance Association states
that the industry exceeded 2.83 billion
in written premium at the end of 2021
and that industry has more than doubled
between 2018 and 2022
that same organization indicates that
over
4.41 million pets are currently insured
across North America
we are here today because while this
Market is fairly new
the regulatory framework around it from
an insurance perspective is light
in light of this explosive growth the
National Association of insurance
Commissioners which I talked a little
bit about during our orientation a few
weeks ago
recognized the growing need for more
standard and comprehensive pet insurance
Frameworks
and so to that end the NAIC developed
the 2022 pet insurance model Act
and this legislation seeks to adopt that
model act into New Hampshire law which
will bring many of the same rules of the
road in consumer protections that are in
the insurance industry to pet insurance
some of the key Provisions include
detailed coverage definitions
disclosures policy conditions sales for
wellness programs best practices for
insurance producer training related
regulations and violations I want to
pause here to highlight something that
representative Burroughs mentioned in
her testimony which is really important
this is a property in casualty product
it is not a health product
though you could easily be forgiven for
being mistaken because so many aspects
of pet insurance resemble
what health insurance looks like for all
of us things like networks and what
types of visits are covered and not
covered things of that nature however at
the end of the day these Provisions
would sit in our property in casualty
statutes and again that is no insult to
the animal lovers Among Us trust me my
family much prefers our pets over me
so I am not offended by that but the way
this works and the law is pets are
property so it will be in the p and C
Realm of the statute
moving on a specific requirements so
again I'm going back to some of the
highlights of the bill specific
requirements that apply to pet insurance
policies regarding how the product may
be sold solicited negotiated or offered
in the state
compliance standards for policies or
certificates of insurance
at the same time the ACT still provides
considerable flexibility for the
industry to Fashion products that are
diverse and attentive to the needs of
consumers for example
insurers may include premium savings
conditions such as yearly or lifetime
limits in exclusions such as different
kinds of veterinary services or
veterinary services rendered outside of
the United States
another key provision applies to
licensing
so training and Licensing of producers
is required within the insurance
industry and pet insurance should be no
different in that regard and so section
7 of the model X spells out the
licensing requirements for producers who
sell pet insurance and the topics that
must be included in that training
required for licensing and the reason
why that is important is because many
states have reciprocity for producers
when training requirements are similar
and this would allow that to happen here
in the in the model Act
we are happy to take your questions of
course but I would say in conclusion
that as the model act worked its way
through the NAIC process and it is a
very long process I'm sure chairman hunt
over the years has seen a few of these
model acts come through they're few and
far between because the process involved
is very very long
but because it brings together a wide
diversity of stakeholders so folks like
folks like ourselves folks in the
industry as well as many other
stakeholders they all have an
opportunity to come to the table and to
have their perspective heard as these
model acts are formed and so that was
certainly the process that was followed
here James do you recall when they
started to put together the model Act
I'm not exactly sure but I I'm pretty
sure it's been a couple of years at
least yeah that's consistent two to
three years is my recollection of it
that it took for this to come together
so again it's a very thorough process
that brings all of the parties to the
table
so in conclusion Mr chairman we believe
that this model act strikes the
appropriate balance between limiting
regulation while also ensuring that when
a consumer has a problem with their
policy that our consumer division has
the tools necessary to assist the
consumer as we do with all other
insurance products so I'll pause for a
moment to turn to my colleagues to see
if I've missed anything
they tell me no
so I'll turn it back over to you Mr
chairman
okay you have any questions
um yeah I'm just I'm just curious so
right now there's no regulation on pet
insurance at all is that correct
well I wouldn't say no regulation at all
they're obviously still applies the
consumer protection act Provisions but
as it pertains to the particular
nuances and and facets of pet insurance
I think that's an accurate statement
yeah so yeah you got to speak to them
like really yeah
as the Deputy Commissioner stated uh the
unusual nature of this is that it is
property Casualty Insurance the way
we're looking at it and all our property
casually statues to do apply uh but it's
a little odd because it's it's you have
your your animal which is the property
but then underneath that um the
insurance companies have put basically a
health insurance program so obviously in
in our PNC statutes we don't have a lot
of discussion of Wellness programs
because it's not a part of PNC so we had
to in essence take those minimum
requirements that we wanted and the
industry wanted and the consumer the
consumers wanted the center for economic
Justice is also also at the table and
basically layer that into a p to a
property casually statute so now you
have all the property casualty
protections and protections that are
mimicking health insurance type
protections which we've never had before
so without those it would be difficult
to say no to a form so this will bring
consistency among all the 50 states when
it's passed by all the states
of one follow-up for the question you
mean Clark I'm just curious so what
happens now like if I had an issue like
how do you guys just guess or is I mean
there must be some what's the process
now if I have so the problem I'd come to
you the process now would be we we would
review the review the form that's the
first part and we apply all the PNC
standards to it and then and we'd have
the the uh the companies kind of company
by company Patchwork putting their their
health insurance in essence a health
insurance type standards in for
pre-existing injury Wellness programs
um things that we don't usually do
um waiting periods for health uh and
then we would have to on a case-by-case
basis uh the commissioner would have to
in essence assert uh individual
determinations he's making uh on what's
in the public interest uh in terms of
blocking things so in this if you have a
statute like the model then you don't
have to worry about just apply the model
and all 50 Commissioners have spoken
about the model okay thank you
representative Gibbs thank you
um if enacted uh what effect if any uh
would this bill have on existing pet
insurance policies and if there would be
um I I would say uh it would have
um some some effects on in essence
bringing all of the different uh pet
insurance policies into alignment with
each other so it would be Apples to
Apples but again this is the minimum
requirement so you know our statutes are
not running industry we're saying these
are the minimum things we'd like to see
in a pet insurance policy to protect
consumers if one insurance carrier wants
to go above that and provide more that
that's fine but these are the minimums
we want to see like we want a 30-day
waiting period we want to only have one
pre-existing period so you have a
pre-existing injury in your animal in
the once it's basically once you get an
event to sign off on the animal and the
after the first policy there's no
pre-existing policy after policy because
in PNC land we think of policies as
one-year contracts it's not quite like
health insurance it's more of a benefits
program so to bring all of those
minimums together all of the insurance
companies now have to adhere to those
and we can enforce those whether up
front or on the back end but all the
bells and whistles above that they can
do what they want to uh further in quick
further further inquiry thank you
um
but if
an existing policy did not meet the
minimum requirements what would the
effect be oh well that would be an
illegal policy then have to refile it
representative Emin
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
our questions I don't see a fiscal note
in the bill could you just go over uh
resource requirements within the
department needed to facilitate this and
so the apartment's already designed to
to do everything that in this area of
insurance already exists so we'll be
doing exactly what we've been doing with
the exact same people there's no added
cost
okay I I must say that reading this
through it's kind of um kind of
entertaining uh but I did see that there
there will be no wellness program many
going forward so so there's no manage
care here there's no managed care and we
have no guaranteed procedures but I was
thinking that it it's sort of like if
anybody wanted to know what health
insurance looked like in New Hampshire
prior to 7-Eleven before prior to the
Affordable Care Act this is it this is
exactly what we were overturning way
back then so
all right see none thank you very much
guys
having no more cards and no more
questions I guess we can
you sure you didn't want to share you're
okay we're all set we will close the
public hearing